companies across the world are already
using artificial intelligence I feel
that very soon government agencies will
also start using this technology we
manually developed understanding of
artificial intelligence thanks to this
course I think I'd be better positioned
to improve business processes within
state government I'm planning to
implement AIML and data analytic
initiatives to improve business
processes within state government hi my
name is Eduardo Marquis I live in Texas
and I'm currently working in the public
sector with state government as a
management analyst in my 20 plus year
long career I've been fortunate to work
in the private sector for several great
companies like IBM Motorola and Dell
working in the public sector is a little
bit different than the private sector
but my experience in both has made me
realize is that technology continues to
be the best Avenue for improving
business operations to provide better
value to our customers especially with
artificial intelligence machine learning
and data analytics in the picture and to
do that you need sufficient knowledge I
wanted to stay informed about the latest
Technologies and to explore growth
opportunities
I chose simply learns artificial
intelligence for decision making course
due to this association with Wharton
my experience has been amazing simply
learn delivers a rewarding and positive
learning experience the content is
relevant and concise and the simply
learn LMS platform is easy to use the
course has been instrumental in
highlighting various use cases that
would allow organizations to benefit by
leveraging Ai and ml to model their HR
and financial business processes now I
know how to use AI for transforming
various business processes successfully
I'm planning to implement AIML and data
analytic initiatives to improve business
processes within state government
and with the new skills that I've
acquired during this course this has
become easier I think that I have opened
doors to many growth opportunities about
Skilling myself and I'll definitely
going to recommend this course to my
peers